[Applaudissements]
mon truc
on va faire la deuxième cabine parce
qu'on va la remplir là on va la remplir
la deuxième cabine
jamel est a quand même un âne déguisé en
zorro fallait y aller l'association
canal anne rocco siffredi ouais mais oui
bien sûr daiane 2e cabine connaît lui
connaît [ __ ] c'est incroyable je vous
dirais tant qu on dira ce que s'est vu
prendre ou 6e s'est pas défilé c'est
magnifique
moi j'ai dit ce que j'ai vu j'ai vu guy
lagache lui impossible
c'est incroyable quand même
guy lagache ans vivent souvent à temps
vous parlez souvent parce qu'il faut
qu'on s'organise on verra les ifp et un
débat
la belle et tais toi on était méchant
c'est incroyable je vois c'est
incroyable et un roselyne bachelot qui
fait des merguez
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai alors guez halal
c'est pas possible à l'annoncé alors
vous dites quoi ce look qui bluffe qui
fait débarquer à l'alcool
j'avais passé qui brille mais non il a
des chances qu'il sait que je veux y
croire je sais pas
à noter exit qu'il a gâché lui qu'est ce
que je te disais syndic sa démission
roselyne cuisine pas je pense que la
gâchette veut nous montrer son savez
étrange moi je fais confiance à jamel et
ckoi et commence à me faire chier si on
prête aux tensions sociales et rappelle
avec lui c'est bon je t'engage quand tu
veux alors isabelle anoh les merguez ça
sentirait vu moi j'ai envie de voir guy
lagache sens qu'elles sont donc 10 et
jamel qui bluffe est trop réfléchi jamel
c'est vous qui avez raison je vous allez
voir c'est trop réfléchi janet c'est
vous qui avez raison mais je m'attends à
ce que savait que dit tout shabelle ici
et une fois qu'on vous donnera la
réponse je vous dirai pourquoi tu
appelles ça réfléchit tout fait des
merguez halal a atteint public vous
pensez est-ce que jamel bluff qui disent
bluff c'est qu'il dit que je bluffe haye
sur plus jamel il pense que j'avais la
raison il pour ceux qui avaient là une
force que j'ai raison vrai attentio
jamel
on va tirer le rideau et sur l'aide sur
attention
[Applaudissements]
c'est des merguez halal picking up qui
ne veulent pas qu ayant des magasins k6
30 tenait d'ailleurs à rose-hill tenez
on voulait on vous les offre halal alors
j'étais contente
jamel est ce que je peux tout raconter
oui moi je te sors avec vous avez dit
jamais la vérité
je vais vous dire pourquoi il a hésité
parce que on est allé derrière la cabine
c'est à dire la vérité et pas vu j'avais
mal lu et j'avais mal lu roselyne ma
part j'ai mal comment la map
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas vrai je dis joue sur an non
c'est pas vrai j'ai tous vos albums tous
se disaient plutôt hachée par les fautes
et le risque et hugo sur la tête de ma
mère j'ai tout télécharger l'étude
m